that's always the worst when you're
basically a shooter and you get spawned
into the shot clock expecting to go
one-on-one James trying to muscle that
in Myrtle got a piece of it but there is
Howard left who dumped it in well using
the G League as his biggest vehicle down
playing time and then exploding last
year paid their dues worked hard to bail
for games and
establishing careers buck pick-and-roll
right there you got to respect Britain
coming off that screens and shoot that
got to cut off my last point then you
gotta keep a body on Davis you gotta
stay in his legs there's a difference
[Applause]
show you that wayward white hits to pass
from Avery and look at that thing go
down lob a much better finishing Pirtle
[Applause]
the good play was the rebound on the
missed by LeBron as he's a Aaron just
flushes at home with LaMarcus didn't do
anything about coaches really go nuts
[Music]
ten nine on the Elbridge free throws
James Davis with a follow-up fit his
size and length and still set the
ability to shoot threes handle the rock
and guard multiple position switch pic
of holes James can't lose contact with
awkward's Carroll white gay and Bill's
for the Spurs and Davis over LA for two
buck pick and roll right there you got
to respect Britain coming off that
screens and shoot that again got to cut
off the last point then you got to keep
a body on dance you got to stay in his
leg 72 he's not even touch it and pull
down you you have to maintain contact
dr. Bob balance he knocks down the
jumper Davis in a game with tabs boards
Tannen DeRozan 12 the double mr score
[Applause]
Davis lied he got me oh yeah